wanna be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you
know there's something more inside you
too you've got michael jordan level
genius at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and get some incredible
motivation from the one and only
kevin o'leary enjoy
everybody has a path in their career
they plan on but it generally doesn't
work out that way
there's a series of events that happen
to you along the way
and you don't know as they're happening
because you only realize how important
they were
maybe a decade later when you realize it
was a huge pivot point for you
mine was when i was working in a summer
job in college
for a pet food company
and i had a german manager really
interesting guy and he
taught me that most pet foods at that
time were made from sea of japan tuna
and chicken faces and beef lips and
rendered you know protein using mango
juice to crush it up sounds horrific
but those are two basic engines and then
they'd add some peas or you know some
carrots and they'd create cat food
flavors
decades later when i was in the software
industry i realized that you know we're
the leader in math and reading software
and here's where this story comes into
play
all my competitors were spending a
fortune building unique
applications to advance reading and math
scores those are the two big things you
actually
create software to advance during
education and i thought to myself that's
crazy this is really just sea of japan
tuna
and chicken faces all we need are two
engines and we'll just add
characters to them and that was how the
learning company became the largest
software
company in the world in reference in
education we sold it for 4.2 billion
but that manager gave me the idea to
synergize around two development groups
so we
we hi you know we buy a company fire
everybody and just take the characters
they had
and we caught our costs dramatically you
know our costs of r d were half the
industries everybody's complaining but
how are we doing it
we're doing it because we understand
that that software is no different than
cat food
you're always competing with somebody
somewhere and these days it's global and
you've got to make the assumption that
the person you're competing with
really loves what they do and they're
willing to work 25 hours a day and if
you're not if you're not
totally in love with it you're screwed
so i would argue an entrepreneur don't
start something that you don't have a
lot of passion for
because you're going to fail because
you're going to be competing with people
who do have that passion who are
motivated
and i see that happen all the time they
just get bored
and you know maybe i've invested in them
and i can see that they're just burned
out
and if that happens you know quite often
i would say probably about 30 percent of
the time
after a while they realize boy this is
hard work yeah it is hard work
running a business is really hard work
but it's an
added bonus if you can get up in the
morning and say i can't wait to go fight
the fight
because you know with certainty your
competitor is doing that so
that is a theme that we can both agree
on you better love it baby
i was working once in an ice cream
parlor when i was about 15 years old
my first real job and on the second day
i was asked to scrape the gum off
between the mexican tiles on the floor
and i said to the woman who owned the
store it was called magoo's ice cream
parlor
you didn't hire me to scrape gum you
hired me
to scoop ice cream and there's this girl
in the shoe store across the way that's
looking at me i don't want to see her
scraping the gum and she said what are
you talking about
i own this store i'll do any anything i
want with you get down on your knees and
scrape that gum
and i said i'm not doing it she said
you're fired
last job i ever had i owe that woman
everything i don't like to work for
people
many of you would hear i hope inherit
that
there's nothing wrong with it if you
want to control your own destiny
you work for yourself that's how it
works
i'm trying to inspire those of you who
are on the tipping point
take the chance you're young go for it
there's nothing better than being able
to wake up in the morning
10 years or 20 years from now and do
whatever
you like
it's about freedom that's what matters
i'm not saying being an employee is bad
but believe me being an entrepreneur is
better
[Music]
i'm a little biased let's talk about
writing books because i'm working on my
fourth now
i'm hating every minute of it but i
think it's going to be my best but i
always say that about every book
how do you do yours this book came when
i was on tour
last year and i was hitting the city
every four days and doing a speech in
front of a group and
the questions that people ask me i just
kept
kept like a note of what people kept
asking me over and over again and then
it turned it into
and then you got thematically you would
get some very
questions over and over again that
people had right you'd say that is a
kernel that's an important question
because they keep getting it all the
time is that the idea
yeah i was on tour and people kept
asking me how do i find my purpose how
do i find my purpose how do i find my
prayers like
the number one question in every city
across america
i said well that's pretty easy you don't
have to
sit on top of a mountain for ten years
or hire twenty thousand dollar business
coach you know
there's a three step process to find
your purpose and i just guided them
through it and then
everyone say pick me pick me do it with
me it's like okay well i'll turn it into
a book
and that became built to serve sounds
good i gotta read that book man that
sounds pretty good
i gotta find my purpose i've really
enjoyed our time today it's great you're
a good guy
i'm gonna endorse you
that's fantastic unfortunately
one of the great benefits of
technology's productivity one of the big
downsides it's incredibly distracting
people check their twitter account or
they'll answer a
facebook message or they'll do something
that has nothing to do with making money
and the reason you go to work in the
morning is to make money
that's what you're there for all the
other wonderful things you can do with
your time
are based on your ability to create an
income for yourself and your family
so why spend any time doing all that
crap
which is distracting and so that's the
number one thing i find
in my companies is when you see someone
failing and you look at how they manage
their time
you'll see right there what's going on
they're not focused on what matters
okay that's simple last time we heard we
talked about your meeting with steve
jobs and i've read a lot about steve
jobs since he passed away and people
talk about how he was so
unbelievably difficult and tough in a
way yes he was would you characterize
him that way yeah
he was a prick yeah but
do you have to be that way to accomplish
what he's done
you know i respect him for the
tremendous success
and the vision he had i was proud to
work for him because that's what i was
doing supplying educational software
i always thought in person he could have
been a nicer guy
but would that have changed the outcome
maybe he was a genius
and and i remember him saying i asked
him about well maybe we should do some
market research
on this before we spend two million
dollars on a particular product we're
doing for reader rabbit he said
we don't do market research we tell them
what they want
and i thought wow not only is that
arrogant
but it's brilliant and it worked right
and so i said
okay big guy let's do it and it was very
successful to
my exposure most of the business people
i've met the successful ones the ceos or
whatever
they are at their core optimistic
can you be a pessimist and be a
successful entrepreneur
you have to be optimistic i think you
have to
view the world in a way that
assumes success otherwise you'll never
have the energy
maybe not a pessimist but a skeptic
is a good thing to be because
what i've learned about business over
all these years and all these deals
it's never as good as it sounds but it's
never as
bad as it looks either you know every
day i've got
32 portfolio companies now something
wildly bad is happening to one of them
and the cell phone rings at six in the
morning
and something fantastically great is
happening to another one
and it seems to me the random
serendipitous nature of it all is really
intriguing to me because
if i could only show the pessimistic or
very
you know depressed entrepreneur that
is calling me saying oh my goodness we
just lost walmart or whatever it is it's
the nightmare of their day versus we
just got walmart on the other business
i'm trying to get everybody in the same
universe to realize it's never as bad as
it sounds
but never as good either you have to get
up in the morning back to work
great entrepreneurs are able to delegate
the successful women's ceos are
remarkably good at this
remarkably good at it and the way it
works is sarah
i'll give you an example the way sarah
works she hires somebody she sets a goal
for 90 days
and gets out of their way gets
completely out of their way
lets them achieve it if they achieve it
she moves them up the organization
if they don't they get three tries until
they're out
if you can't achieve your goals in
business that's what happens
but her whole thing is let them do the
work themselves let them figure it out i
don't want to use my time for it that's
what i hired them for
i listen to my gut it's not scientific
i've learned over time and i think every
entrepreneur should
trust their um feelings because i've
learned
every time i don't listen to my gut i
lose money
every time i say to myself no you're
wrong with that i second guess myself
i lose money you have to listen
successful entrepreneurs have a spider
sense i really believe that they know
what's right they know what's wrong
they have to listen to themselves and it
doesn't always work out but the minute
you second guess yourself you're screwed
you really are you're no longer a leader
people that follow you
into dark places have to trust you and
you have to trust yourself
the key to success as an entrepreneur is
not to understand your strengths is to
understand your weaknesses
now here's what i knew i was weak at
logistics
manufacturing and shipping logistics
bores the crap out of me i'm just
not interested in it when walmart came
on board and said look we're going to
change this whole industry we're going
to make you our guys in education
software
we had the challenge of moving 80
million units
i can't do that that's not my skill set
michael perrick
on the other hand is myopically focused
at that kind of thing and i knew that he
was one of our shareholders i went and
approached him and said listen
why don't you leave your pe firm okay
i'll give up the title of ceo you're
going to be the ceo
your number one role is going to be
logistics because if we're not
successful at this we're going to fail
this is the only thing that matters is
shipping these units
all around the world he looked at me and
said what's in it for me i said you know
what i own a ton of stock
lots and lots of it i'll make a deal
with you i'll make you that's equal
partners
and this is how and in the book in
writing it i looked at every transit
transaction
where i've made money not just learning
companies storage now
larry funds deals before that
all the deals where i made money were
partnerships all the ones where i had
catastrophic failures are things i tried
to do myself
so i've learned now that it's much
better to partner with
with somebody who actually fills in the
hole every entrepreneur i meet is very
passionate that's just part of the
equation i actually
argue that what matters most
is executional skills every
entrepreneur's passion
everybody that's an entrepreneur is
ready to
to take that journey and and go down
that road and that's great
but the ones that are still doing it
three years later have executional
skills
so that's what i think matters above
everything else i meet lots of teams i
fund lots of companies
i see lots of failure and lots of
successes the difference is
men and women primarily women these days
that can really execute that set goals
tell you what they are talk to you every
three months saying i achieved this goal
or i didn't
and why and to me that's the building
block of a business
there's nothing worse than vision all
day long
vision's easy execution is hard
but do you really literally mean that if
you are in business you have to be
willing to fire your mom
you know it's true you do because
in the end when you create a business
and you start one
many entrepreneurs in this audience will
understand this comment
your allegiance has to be to the
business first
because without that all the good things
that you want to do are going to fail
and so as your business grows and you
make decisions about
individual people you can't let
your emotion get in the way of
what you really need to do which is the
drive success of the business
and so the minute you get your first
customer you now become number two
the minute you get your first investor
now you're number three
the minute you hire your second employee
or your number four
it's still your business but now you
know who you have to serve
and i think a lot of entrepreneurs that
fail don't understand that you're always
serving someone
a shareholder a customer the business
and if you lose sight of that by letting
your emotions get in the way and this
often happens certainly happened to me
in early days
many people hire their friends they
start a company with their friend
or with their brother good way to end a
friendship or you're it's a family
business
and very often nepotism
is what kills the golden goose because
very often the better manager is not
your sister brother uncle cousin
whatever
and i live through this all the time in
the companies that i'm an investor and i
have 32 portfolio companies now
i watch this happen every day and i
don't let emotion get in the way of the
true pursuit of what matters the success
of the business
the only reason you add employees is
sales is growing
you don't add employees unless revenue
is increasing because you can't afford
them
if you have sales growth then you have
to start thinking about getting support
people
so your customer service level stays in
the top quartile
that's when you hire people you're
always keeping your eye on how do i
service my
customers how do i make sure my
employees are happy how to make sure my
investors are happy those are the three
constituencies
but number one is you've got to have
happy customers
and the reason you bring on the risk of
that extra overhead is
you need employees to do that so no
hiring anybody
until your sales go up every time you
double your sales
you should add a couple of people to do
customer service and support in all
areas of the business whether it's
accounting
whether it's you know what you do online
to support them whether it's marketing
with
sales those people are supporting
customers at the end of the day that's
how it works
no hiring anybody until sales go up how
can i overcome my self-doubt
and other people's opinions especially
my close ones like my family
and how can i grow my business to the
next level
swapnal fantastic question you know
every entrepreneur has
self-doubt it's just that you don't want
to show it to the outside world people
want to follow somebody that knows where
they're going
but you have to be able to deal with
your insecurity you can't let your
family tell you you don't know what
you're doing knowing you have a burning
desire to be an entrepreneur
the key to success though is to find
somebody that augments your skills
if you're great in one area find someone
who's better in another
that you're weak in that's how you can
really reduce your self-doubt and make
your outcomes
much better because you're reducing your
risk by getting a partner in the
business
but don't let someone tell you can't do
it that's just crap
particularly your family many people are
jealous about entrepreneurs they want to
try but they don't have the guts to do
it
even within a family that happens
doesn't mean you don't love them
it's just you're not listening to them
when they give you all that naysayer
stuff
stay focused on the goal and deal with
your insecurities everybody has them
are salespeople born or are they made
well everybody's
born but the way i look at it is great
salespeople
are able to live with very strict
metrics
so when i i i hire all my salespeople
and i what i try and look for
in them is can they get up in the
morning and say
i want to go to bed at night richer than
i woke up that's the hallmark of a great
salesman because they're paid on
commissions
that's how it works you know sales is
tough and only two-thirds of your sales
force are going to work out long-term
most of my firings occur in the sales
area because it's clear to me it's not
working
it's a combination of relationships a
little art a little science
and in an organization the people i
respect the most are not the cfos the
cfos
it's the sales people that's where i
have a kid to speak i'm guessing it
came from your mother but what would you
say was the best piece of financial
advice or business advice you ever got
in your
long lengthy career when i was seven and
my brother was five
she'd take us to the bank with her um
you know to because that's where you
would buy bonds back in those days you
could actually buy the certificate
with the coupons every six months you'd
clip them off
she'd say to us boys never spend the
principal only the interest i had no
idea what she was talking about that's
all i do today
[Music]
in my world you never touch your
principal you adjust
your spending habits your gifts to
charities your use of capital based
on how much you can generate from your
portfolio
i view my portfolio and my trust and my
positions
as a chicken on a spit dripping cash
everything has to generate yield whether
it's a fixed income position
or an equity it has to the only reason
it can be in my world is
generating capital back to me i take
that i disburse it the family lives off
that the charities i've committed to
so i'm always looking for a company that
can help me with my problem of
generating more yield
everything that i mean i can't even
imagine buying a stock that doesn't pay
a difference why would you do that
what would be the reason you would do
that i don't get it so to me
that means about 28 of the market
to me is just speculation a staff that
doesn't pay a dividend is a speculation
it's not an investment what areas of the
world do you like right now where you're
investing
you know i look at it very
simplistically i say where's the gdp
growth because that's the rising tide
for any operation
a telco a toll road a consumer goods
company you'd rather own that in a
country that has gdp growth north of
three percent
so right now you know i used to be 70
percent invested in canada
i'm down to less than 25 here because
we're not growing we're not growing in
the us
i like brazil india china asia cambodia
thailand
they got it cooking over there they're
growing so i'd rather
own the brazilian telco than any
canadian telco i mean you look at the
the worst returns in telco or in canada
you can buy a brazilian telco that's
been a phenomenal investment for the
last five years
and the great thing about these
companies overseas is they're so big now
so huge they're issuing the securities
in u.s dollars and i can hedge that back
to the canadian dollar for next to
nothing
people say well you have to be a really
nice guy to make money that's not true
make lots of money money goes to the
path of least resistance it doesn't care
about
your personality it's looking for an
opportunity to grow and expand with the
least risk
with the least you know resistance to
success
so i've learned that i work with many
people that i would never be friends
with
but i make money with them and i respect
them for that many many many people
i i can certainly keep the emotion of
that decision i'm not sure how you're
going to take this story but i'm going
to tell you many ways okay
end of a class nine at night
600 people there's a fellow up at the
top puts up his hand and say mr o'leary
look
i have to ask you a question i haven't
said anything all class but i'm
really hurting can you help me and i
said what's your problem
class goes dead silent because it's not
going to be about business
and he said today
my fiancee came to me and said that i
have to make a decision
between our relationship and the
business
and i said oh i'm not dr dr phil here
but
let's let's hear it this guy had
in his dorm room in undergrad
engineering built
an online cloud-based compliance tool
for hedge funds
with under 250 million to help them
reduce their cost
subscription service the guy had a run
rate of 5 million dollars
he hadn't even graduated yet i'm licking
my
chops at this business this is fantastic
and then he said but i have no time and
i never see my fiancee she wants me to
come be with the family on sundays
just once but i'm doing my compliance
downloads on sundays and i have to deal
with my customers because i got to go
back to class at
8 o'clock in the morning on monday now
the class is
looking at me saying okay big guy what's
the answer
i said everybody let's be pragmatic
which is easier to replace your business
or your fiance
and the fan with that but let me ask you
something let me ask you something
clearly that match was not right because
if you're going to get into a
relationship with an entrepreneur man
and woman
it doesn't matter you have to understand
what drives them
it's not going to be a successful union
it's not going to work
i think he made the right decision
what's what's the value of a stock
that never returns capital to its
shareholders i don't know
because the only way you can make money
is if somebody else is willing to buy
that position
at a higher price for some emotional
reason perhaps or
for some you know foresight that maybe
the company will
return capital one day and i think of
you know what when you learn as an
investor
over multiple decades is the only thing
that matters is free cash flow
that's it there is no other reason to
own a stock
and with that philosophy it brings you
into a place
where you focus on the company's ability
to
generate incremental cash flow because
just
owning a dividend paying stock is not
good enough because you know
let's say we find a stock today that's
paying a three percent dividend yield
and tomorrow because
it's forecast for sales get cut in half
the stock drops by 50
now it's yielding six percent i don't
want to own that stock either
so my tests in this index that i've you
know created with ftse russell
looks at the balance sheet every year we
test to make sure that the company is
viable
in its ability to generate cash this is
extremely conservative investing this is
for the long
haul these tools are not for as you're
suggesting
for spicy you know the hot stock du jour
i've done that i've been there you know
let the young legs do that i have zero
interest in that i don't care what the
hot new stock is
you know when when a company comes
public i won't own it either it's got to
prove to me
over multiple years that i can continue
to generate cash
before it even fits into what i'm doing
so
i'm really boring and i like it that way
if you come and tell me
you're the ceo you're the founder you're
the largest shareholder that you know
and you're perfect at everything i know
you're full of crap
that that is so not true great
entrepreneurs
know their weaknesses and surround
themselves with solutions
the logistics person the marketing
person the accounting person
the sales woman the salesman i'll tell
you something
nobody has a monopoly on great ideas
nobody there's
always somebody with a problem that
needs to be solved and that is the
essence
of a great business opportunity look
around you in the world and see the
problems people are having
keep your eyes open and when you
discover one that you think you can fix
that is the beginning of a business my
friend that's how it starts
so don't be down and don't say that all
the great ideas are taken that's never
the case
there's always the next great idea and
that's what's wonderful about being an
entrepreneur
you got to keep sort of your mind open
and your eyes open and always be looking
for opportunity
and don't be depressed i don't like that
tone let's get happy
and let's get focused and let's get to
work and by the way
the greatest companies ever started were
many that were started with no money
it's not about money it's about solving
somebody's problem
if you can solve a problem you can start
a business even with no cash
you're going to provide as much as you
can for the little as you can to start
it and prove it out
you get a product or service that people
are buying and they're saying this works
for me you're solving a problem
that's the beginning of a great journey
my advice to
people that want to be mavericks
is put your blinders on focus on what
you want to achieve and don't listen to
all the noise
that noise is horrific and just really
really bad
and it's always going to be eating at
you but you've got to stay focused on
the goal
i was taught that years ago by a mentor
and it's absolutely true
stay focused don't let distractors
bother you don't let them get you down
and invariably you're going to be kicked
to the ground
as a maverick or an entrepreneur or
anybody that's trying to achieve their
own
freedom but you got to get up and keep
going whatever you do
somebody can do it better you have to
bring your a game in
every single day there's nothing unique
about
any one individual what's unique is
their passion
their ability to execute to meet targets
and exceed them
the minute you lose that ability
in capitalism you're gone
it's a fair trade the engine that makes
you rich
can take it all away from you there are
no guarantees
i think that's incredibly important if
you think you can
have a balanced life as an entrepreneur
that's just
there's some other guy that wants your
customer that's working 25 hours a day
right that's what i found and so i don't
i don't even talk about that anymore
saying look it's a great you have to
decide
it's a path you either are going to
control your own destiny
or you're going to be an employee
they're both they're both noble one
gives you time to be with your family
one gives you a more balanced life and
the other one is
balls to the wall and the reason you do
it is to eventually have personal
freedom because you've been successful
and i think most people in this room
fall into that second category balls to
the walls
and they're going to make it or they're
not and
that's why i come here because i the
kindred spirit i like to see
entrepreneurs that are willing to risk
it all
but but have to realize there is no
balance the reason you
do and pursue an entrepreneurial career
is to provide financial freedom one day
for yourself and your family
the sacrifice is there's no balance
during the period you're growing the
business if you're successful
the reward is financial freedom which is
the essence
you know i tell young entrepreneurs
don't do it for the great of money
do it for financial freedom do it for
freedom make yourself free one day so
you can do whatever you wish with your
time
and the only way you can do that in our
society is you have to be wealthy to do
that
and so the rewards of a great
entrepreneur are
they achieve that wealth and they're
free to do whatever they wish which may
be more entrepreneurship
you don't know if you're passionate and
you're successful
you'll wake up you'll wake up one day
rich
you won't really be going for the cash
it'll just happen to you
everybody i talked to that said success
doesn't remember the day
they became a millionaire no idea
not important to them they remember
winning
they remember building a business and
being successful
again the pursuit of freedom manifests
itself in passion
that's really what it's about how do you
get to the next level you hire amazing
people
and you give them a piece of the upside
very hard to do in a services business
is like yours but not
impossible scale is everything you want
to get bigger
the only way you're going to do that is
expanding on being just a one-man
show and that's tough finding the right
partners that should augment your skills
you know if you're great in one thing
like sales and marketing
get someone who's better in logistics or
hiring people that can actually do more
of these websites
i've always found in every one of my
deals that made me money it's the team i
built
a fantastic team of people working
together towards a single mission
the better the people the more money i
made it's that simple but i always
gave up some to them so they were part
of the story and i always found even if
i gave up half which i did in the case
of the learning company
that outcome was 4.2 billion dollars so
i was pretty happy with the outcome in
the long run
it's all about team it's really hard to
do it on your own
and building a team you have to build it
slowly and find the right
partners and then give them some of the
upside i like gold because
in a way it's a stabilizer it's an
insurance policy
you know i listen to all the gold
pundits and they're always wrong as far
as i'm concerned it's possible to time
the moves
i've owned gold for decades and i simply
have a five percent waiting
i look at it quarterly when it becomes
more than five percent i sell into the
strength
and when it weakens i buy into the
weakness it's just a stabilizer
you know i'm not one of those guys
that's going to go to 40 waiting in gold
i don't believe the hyperinflation story
it hasn't happened gold is
popular for a whole host of reasons and
5 seems to be enough it's worked for me
in portfolio management it's the only
security i own that doesn't pay a
dividend
so kevin i guess do you not care if gold
goes to two thousand or five thousand
dollars an ounce you're still going to
buy gold
yeah i don't care like let it let it run
i'll be selling into that strength
keeping it five percent waiting
you know what i've learned i'm an old
crusty investor
when everybody's saying you got to own
it you should be selling it because when
it corrects it doesn't touch the sides
on the way down
so i simply say 5 is good for me some
people like it 10 15
waiting i'm a 5 guy and i'm disciplined
about it i hope it runs to 5000. i don't
care i'll be selling selling selling
selling and selling all the way up
keeping it five percent and when it
corrects back down to 2000 i'll be
buying it in
it's fun that's the way you should work
with gold never get so caught up that
you take all your dividend yielding
securities that are also a hedge against
inflation
and put it into a commodity like gold
diversification
is the only free lunch in investing and
i see this happen
so many times here's my basic lesson
that i've learned that i never vary from
and this works trust me it works never
more than five percent of your portfolio
in any one name
no matter how great the story is if it's
the next nortel if it's the next rim
who cares five percent max weighting for
me usually it's two and a half to three
percent i never let a stock get bigger
than that
in my portfolio i sell into the strength
all the time
secondly never ever ever more
than any one sector so if you love gold
you just can't get past 20
of your net worth in gold or energy or
any other sector or financial services
so good sectoral diversification is
crucial
and finally for me i'm over 60
weighted in debt now versus equity not
government debt
not treasury bonds but corporate debt
remember that a double b
or triple b bond is serviced before they
pay the dividend on a common stock
so i like to own right up the balance
sheet so i own a lot of press converts
senior debt floating rate notes i love
that stuff
because when they get upgraded i get
capital appreciation meanwhile i get a
check
the key to life is the check coming in
it's the cash
if you always always always look at the
free cash flow
this will keep you safe because the only
friend you're going to have when you're
old and crusty
is not your dog not your kids it's the
cash in the bank that's still going to
love you
i have a definition of what is a hobby
and what is a business
by saying if you can't make money within
36 months which is three years which is
a big number for me in business
it's just a hobby and it's not a
business if you're still losing money
after three years
you should treat it for what it is you
know a use of your time that is not
productive but you enjoy it for other
reasons
if you can't make it profitable after
all that time it is just a hobby and if
you're using all your time to spend on
it
then you're not an entrepreneur you're
not creating something where you can
create
jobs and provide services to people
you're just wasting your time and
wasting your money
take it behind the barn and shoot it
that's my definition i was working once
in a nice screen parlor
when i was about 15 years old my first
real job
and on the second day i was asked to
scrape the gum
off between the mexican tiles on the
floor and i said to the woman who owned
the store it was called magusai screen
parlor
you didn't hire me to scrape gum you
hired me
to scoop ice cream and there's this girl
in the shoe store across the way that's
looking at me i don't want to see her
scraping the gum and she said what are
you talking about
i own this store i'll do any anything i
want with you get down on your knees and
scrape that gum
and i said i'm not doing it she said
you're fired
last job i ever had i owe that woman
everything i don't like to work for
people
many of you would hear i hope inherit
that
there's nothing wrong with it if you
want to control your own destiny
you work for yourself that's how it
works
the majority is of my the majority or
many i should say of my employees and
the employees of the supply chain that
supplies our companies
because we're very integrated with our
supply chain
have no investment strategy at all they
don't have
anything saved they have nothing planned
for their retirement
and they're in their you know mid-20s to
early 30s
that is insane and you know because
it got exposed to me because we were
talking about payroll
you know and the ppp loan took a
snapshot of your payroll feb 15th and
where it was going to be june 30 or june
15th and so we got into these
discussions with our employees and i was
shocked
nobody has any savings or any investment
strategy
and there's a difference between saving
and investing anyways because
if you don't start putting aside at
least a hundred dollars a week
if you've got a job you will have
nothing at the end of your career
to live off if you invest a hundred
dollars a week a minimum
you could have as much as a million
three million four million five
depending on how the markets perform
over the next forty years
i've learned a different tact what i do
is i try and bring someone into a
company or in my own group
for six months on a trial basis to see
if they interact with the team and tell
them honestly and transparently look
we don't know if it's going to work why
don't you come in as an intern why don't
you check it out
how do you see how you feel and then if
we really gel
you stay on there's nothing worse than
bringing you know a cancer
into your body that's the way i look at
it and you want somebody that's
on board and can work with everybody
else and i like to hire very slowly and
fire
very quickly and i tell that to all my
ceos and i think people gravitate
of they might be too nice and then one
bad thing happens so then they go
and they say well now i'm going to be
extra tough yeah and
and then you build a different kind of
culture but that's not actually who you
are and then you try to
you know it's just finding that flow for
who you are in the kind of business you
want to build but you want to be with
people that
want to be with you and everybody shares
a common vision and i think that's the
new
entrepreneur 2.0 is making sure that
hey you have a social mission that you
care and you're all in sync with and b
or have a profit motivation because
that's how you keep the business intact
and if anybody's not on board with your
vision your direction
they shouldn't be there and they don't
they don't want to be there long term
so i i look at it and say are we all
singing from the same song sheet
let's test that every few months let's
sit around and ask each other is
everybody happy who's unhappy
and just bring it out i think that's
listen it sounds kumbaya but it works
when i was growing up
i was born from immigrants and irish and
lebanese and irish father lebanese
mother
and by the time i hit seven it was clear
i had some really big problems in math
and reading
going back to education because i had a
really bad case of dyslexia
and so in those days dyslexic you know
outcomes were bad because you really
fell behind in school and they didn't
really understand how it worked
and luckily i was very fortunate my
mother was desperate she was trying to
find a solution for this because
i was falling behind really quickly in
those critical years in in early school
and so she found this woman named
marjorie golick who had an experimental
sam rabinovich and marjorie golovka
researchers they're published all around
the world now
but they basically thought they could
take the selected children
after school maybe 12 or 18 and put them
into an experimental program
where they try and convince the kids
that dyslexia is actually a superpower
that other people don't have
so that your confidence really advances
and that's that's what they ended up
doing with me they said look
do you know anybody else in your class
that can read a book upside down in a
mirror
no you're the only guy that can do it
that's power they wish
they could do it they can't and so that
started giving me the confidence because
dyslexia doesn't really [ __ ] learning
it just makes the the incumbent tools in
schools useless to you
i mean nobody gives you a book upside
down in a mirror you have to learn how
to deal with what dyslexia does
and that once i had that solved it was a
very interesting acceleration that
occurred
and you find in business today all kinds
of founders of companies like the guy
that founded jetblue
a really bad case of dyslexia i think it
it helps you think outside of the box
and i've always thought business is half
creativity that comes from the chaos of
the arts and half the discipline of
science
business is binary you either make money
you lose it i think great ceos
great entrepreneurs combine the chaos of
art with the discipline
of science and and i believe that to be
the case and i look for that in the
people i invest in now
and i think that dyslexic you know chaos
for me
was was a pivotal point and a catalyst
that i could build
some of my you know direction off very
often being
honest with your customer explaining the
dilemma you're in and how much you want
to help them
is the best way to do it instead of
using a factor that's going to cost you
17
go to the customer say look if you
confront me 30 or 40 percent of this
order i'll fulfill all of it because i
want to service you i want to do
everything in my power
i'd start there factoring is very
expensive all of my shark tank companies
go through this dilemma all the time
factoring is expensive there's no
question it's generally all of your
profit to get cash flow
to keep the business moving and scale it
up and be more productive
but the customer can be your first line
of defense
and they may want to help you the way
i've just suggested ask for 30 to 50
up front on that order if they trust you
they may consider it
there's a huge sacrifice that people
don't think about you know
most people think i'm going to start a
company two months later it's going to
be worth a billion dollars
and i'm going to be make a fortune that
is actually not what happens to 99 of
people
8 out of 10 fail they have to do it
three times they spend a decade before
they get their hit
or they work at one company for 15 years
and they finally get an exit
it's more like that and the personal
sacrifice is huge
there is no soccer game on saturday
there's no sunday dinner with the family
you're working because some guy in china
or india
or some woman out there is kicking your
ass
because we're in a global competition
now and so
i don't care what your business is men
women
you have to understand that you're going
into a a
a huge lifestyle change and i tell
people it's not for everybody
don't do it if you don't have the
stamina to get kicked around
and driven into the ground and get up
and do it again and beaten up by people
that tell you
this is not kumbaya stuff this is
hardcore stuff
how do you deal with your emotions
i'm curious to know richard what a
fantastic question you're
absolutely right your emotions can be
your best friend but also
your worst enemy because when you make a
rational decisions that are based on
sheer emotion
you're often making the wrong decision
and yet emotions are part of your
intuitive gut feel
you have to understand them i find the
best way to do it
is don't be impulsive i get pissed off
too i get angry i get
elation i get all of those things too
but what i've learned over time is not
to make decisions under the influence of
any of those emotions
just delay the decision until you can be
rational
maybe sleep on it get up in the morning
have a coffee and think about it and if
you're not comfortable yet
don't make the decision there's always
the option to do nothing for a while
and what the only way you're going to
learn that's to experience all the
decisions i made under
heavy duress or emotional stress have
cost me a fortune
big mistakes and also you know revenge
is a stupid emotion it makes you do
stupid things
be rational about it doesn't mean you
can't you know
be pragmatic but being motivated by
hatred or fear or anything like that is
never a good outcome i've come to a new
place in my understanding what works and
doesn't i also went through the
educational process
i did an mba and people ask me does that
have anything to do with success or
failure and i say no it doesn't
i don't remember a single thing i
learned there for the two years
except the people i met that that now
are out there in the world as bankers
and lawyers and whatever else they are
and i use them as my bit database of
contacts to help build my businesses so
i think that was important but
the classes that i forget completely
what it was about
i will say one thing though i've learned
something from what the europeans do
evan and listen to this in switzerland i
have a stepfather who swiss he lives in
geneva switzerland i've been going over
there for
40 years back and forth take a company
like nestle
they offer an internship program that
they call an apprentice program over
there it's it's almost like the
sorcerer's helper in a disney movie
in high school if you think you like
the food industry maybe you know nestle
is a global food company
they'll let you come in and work on
weekends and afternoons after school
to see what it's like in the real world
even though you're just a teenager
why are they doing that they're trying
to figure out
who is going to be the next asset for
their company that is going to be
someone who attaches themselves to the
business maybe long term
so they get to try you out you get to
try them out
they pay you a small stipend but that's
an apprenticeship
what an opportunity for you you're a
teen
you're sitting in a meeting with a bunch
of managers you're absorbing all that
stuff
and you're learning why the hell don't
we do that in north america because
maybe one out of 10 is the right person
but once you're indoctrinated if that's
the right word
into the call it the nestle program
you're a nestlet
you're there they want you you want them
and a way your career goes
i love it i think every company in north
america should take that program on and
and
offer this opportunity to kids and their
teens and say look
you want to see what work is you want to
see what it's like
get in here but it also gives you a
chance as an entrepreneur to say i
understand the corporate structure and
now i want to try something a little
different
on my own but i will have had that base
of information not only about what it's
like
but that sector if you love the food
industry
you're with the el supremo and you're
learning about it and then one day you
can split off and say hey nestle i'm
going to build this food business you
want to buy from you have to guess the
50 million
that's the program i like i tell
entrepreneurs today and i invested so
many of them
you know when i say to them look you're
starting this journey i want you to
understand something this
is not going to be fun all the time
you're going to work 25 hours a day
eight days a week because there's some
guy in mumbai or shanghai that's going
to kick your ass if you don't
and it's forever and it's forever but
what will happen if you're successful
and you won't see it coming you wake up
one day
and say oh my goodness i i'm wealthy
beyond my wildest dreams
you'll probably go right back to work
but the point is you created something
of tremendous value
and the way it manifests itself to you
later in life is it gives you freedom to
do whatever you want
my number one message to entrepreneurs
and i teach today is
never pursue entrepreneurship for the
greater money it has nothing to do with
it
at all the whole reason to be an
entrepreneur is the pursuit of freedom
that's why you do it you do it because
you want to be free one day to do
whatever you like
i'm here because i want to be here i
don't have to be here i don't have to
ever listen to a phone call again if i
don't want to that's not what i want to
do i enjoy
spending my time doing the things that i
want to do
and i and i deserve it because i worked
like hell to get here
one year ago i started a construction
and development company with no loans or
investors
so far has gone very well and just in
the last six months we have had 1.5
million dollars in revenue
with well over 200 000 in net profit
after paying myself
we have incredible growth slotted for
next year based on signed contracts
my issue is i'm feeling guilty paying
myself so early in the company life
after hearing the sharks and other
entrepreneurs stories i just want your
opinion on when it is okay to start
giving yourself a salary
thanks mr wonderful justin you're a rock
star my friend
good for you that's absolutely
spectacular that's what it takes the
guts to get
out there and start i'm really excited
for you now look i got some advice here
okay number one
there's nothing wrong with paying
yourself particularly from what i'm
listening to you can afford it
but the key to that is you're taking it
out of the company and investing it in
something else that's completely
different
that justin is the concept of
diversification so you put it into an
etf or you put it into the stock market
you put it into bonds
but it has nothing to do with your
construction business because what you
find in life is what you get too
concentrated and you leave all the money
in the business
and something happens and believe me in
life poop what happens
you're wiped out you don't want that to
happen you're starting your
diversification now so let's say you
pull out 50 000
basically have to live off it but if you
can keep 10
or 15 of what you're taking out and
invest it in something completely
different
like a portfolio of stocks and bonds
that's how you get
wealthy long term i don't think
everybody should be an entrepreneur i
actually think only a third of the
people can handle what it takes because
it is a
really hard gig you know people try to
make it exciting
running a business is a [ __ ] it's hard
as hell
and not everybody wants to sacrifice the
lifestyle requirement
to do it you're giving up a lot i mean
you're not going to hit all those soccer
games on the weekend you're not going to
go to the family picking you're going to
miss a lot of stuff in your young kids
lives
because you're just working because your
competitor is working that way
i think it's a sacrifice how could
senior executives
who was at the pinnacle in their career
effectively invest
in their personal branding v
an amazing question personal branding is
really interesting one of the reasons
i'm doing this youtube channel is to
talk to people directly to see what i'm
really like when i'm outside of the
shark tank
you know i'm not wearing a suit right
now i'm just being honest with you about
the decisions i have to make every day
like everybody else does
i'm an ordinary person like anybody else
that focuses on the tasks i got to get
done during the day
but you you raise a really interesting
question personal branding is about
integrity and honesty
because people smell it from a mile away
these days and so
you've got to be honest with people even
when it's hard
to be honest it's important to be honest
because
your reputation you know is very takes
very long time to build and you can lose
it just like that if people feel you're
being dishonest
when you're an entrepreneur there's so
much noise coming at you there's so much
distracting you and you're trying to
make everybody happy and you're trying
to solve
problems for everybody that works for
you and the customers that you have
and it's so powerful that sometimes you
lose
focus sometimes you forget why you're
there
you have to set goals both short and
long term
and stay myopically focused on achieving
those
you have to shut out the noise you have
to shut out the criticism
you have to shut out the haters the guys
that are hassling you the people are
calling you
your competitors all that stuff and
you're going to have all that you're
going to have
all of that stuff and that's all
distracting
if you have the ability to just shut
that out of your head
you'll be successful because you stay
focused on the prize
people are very very challenging to work
with sometimes you're gonna find that
out
it doesn't mean you can't work with them
but if you're trying to make everybody
happy
you will make everybody unhappy
eventually because you can't do it
you have to think about three things
your customers
are you taking care of them two your
employees you're taking care of them
and number three your shareholders are
the people who loan you the money run
your business
they are what you spend your time on 24
7. you can't solve all the world's
problems you can't take care of every
baby whale
you can't clean up all the oceans
overnight
you have to stay focused on your
business to make that successful
then after you've become successful and
hopefully you will
you can start focusing on all the other
things that are really important to you
but if you try and do that at the
beginning before you solve for your
customers
your employees and your shareholders
you're going to fail
and that's what many many young
entrepreneurs don't understand you've
got to have a myopic focus to shut out
that noise
i know it's not easy to do that and
making people unhappy with you because
you're so razor focused
can often feel troubling to you but if
you can't do that you're not a leader
if you can't do that you will not be a
successful entrepreneur
if you can't focus
you just won't make it so remember that
these are tough love
suggestions all right it's just the
nature of how it works
but if you can and you ask me what makes
entrepreneurs successful
myopic focus on the long-term and
short-term goals and not letting
anything else distract them business is
competitive
get over it it's it's a form of war in
some ways
and you will never ever ever get
everybody
like you ever and if you spend your time
worrying about that you will fail for
sure
you can't care about what people think
as long as you think you're doing the
right thing
they'll end up respecting you they may
not like you that's certainly my
situation
i don't care if you like me i care that
you respect me and that i
am being honest with you about what i
expect you to do for me if you're
working for me or if i'm investing in
you
if you want to be an entrepreneur you
got to get up in the morning understand
there's some guy in mumbai or shanghai
or somewhere in china that wants to kick
your ass and it's coming for you 24 7
because it's true but if you can deal
with all that you'll be okay
when you meet with people that can help
you grow your career or
get your objective done or help you with
your mandate think about it this way
because this is advice i give to
everybody that's trying to get a job or
move up or even advance their own
business
if you had 15 minutes with somebody you
wanted to work with
and you talk about yourself for those 15
minutes
that's a mistake what you should be
talking about is how you can solve
problems for them all the hires in my
companies and the people i hire within
my own you know venture capital firm and
private equity firm
are people that came to me with really
short resumes
basically one line saying i need to meet
you because i'm going to solve some big
problems for you and help you build your
business a lot faster
that's it i'm interested i want to hear
what you have to say i don't care where
you went to high school what the name of
your dog was
i couldn't care less but if you've done
some work and you can tell me how you
can advance what i'm trying to do
you're hired kendall and then i'll give
you six months to go prove it
do that all the time and it really works
think about that think about talking to
people about how you can affect
their outcome i'm a manager at 19 years
old
lately i've been running into some
problems with some staff being
insubordinate
when asking them to do simple tasks i'm
not sure how to go about disciplining
them
what makes it a bit awkward for me is
that i'm probably the youngest person in
my organization or one of the youngest
so often i find people disregard my
authority how can i go around this
the right way raza
19 year old manager born
to lead my friend that's what it sounds
like to me
19 years old here's the key to being a
successful manager
people don't have to like you they have
to respect you
and you have to respect them too great
managers in life and i've gone through
this
my career you don't have to like the
people that work for you but you have to
show them respect and they have to
reciprocate that
in managing companies it's all about
respect and it's
primarily setting goals for people
and asking them to buy into those goals
and agreeing with you
that those are achievable and giving
them at least three months to go achieve
them
so i wouldn't get worried about the
social impact or the concerns about
being a manager at 19
it doesn't matter how old you are it's
irrelevant
it matters if people are willing to
follow you respect you
listen to you work with you and set
goals together that you both achieve
if you can do that at 19 you are a
friggin rock star my friend
and i have a sense that maybe you are
but remember
show respect and respect something that
you don't have
experience because when you're 19 you
don't have any of that so if you meet
somebody that's
working for you that's a lot older
respect what they know
that you don't it's all about respect do
you believe there's such a thing as
work-life balance
no no i don't buy that um
and i tell my entrepreneurs if you if
you're going to take that life and you
want to be an entrepreneur and build a
company there is no work-life balance
you sacrifice your personal life to
pay for freedom later in life when
you're young
and you're working you know 10 12 14
hours a day
you're giving up the soccer game if you
have kids you're giving up the picnic
and all that stuff
but you're doing it so that when you're
in your 50s and 60s
you choose to do whatever you like i
retired for three years and my mandate
for that 36 month period was to visit
every beach on earth
every beach every beach that was
legendary
you know in cambodia in cyprus in
tunisia
i hit them all i got really bored you
should not
risk your family's well-being what you
should do
is work at night and on weekends on
something you're passionate about
to find out whether or not it's going to
work before you take the leap
if you can actually prove what product
or service has demand and people start
buying it from you
you can do it like everybody else does
it's a side hustle until it has enough
critical mass for you to jump
ship that way you don't take a huge risk
i would not risk my family's income
but if you know something that you
really like you can pursue it at nights
and on weekends yeah it becomes tough to
go to soccer games and picnics
but that's okay because you're pursuing
that dream at 38 you're not that old
you can definitely take a risk but
you're not going to give up your primary
income until you have enough proof of
concept
proof of customer proof of sales proof
of cash flow and all those things can be
done over a couple year period of doing
it as a side hustle
that's how entrepreneurs in your
situation get started i get a lot of
flack for
you know telling the truth
i'm the only shark that tells the truth
because think about your your 10 years
as an entrepreneur
you have x number of years it breaks my
heart
to see someone spend months and then
years and then all of their family's
money on a really stupid idea
it's better to face the truth and
give up that pursuit and start another
one the great thing about
entrepreneurship is if you fail you try
again
but after three years if you're if
you're not making any money it's a hobby
it's not a business
i think being a skeptic makes you test
your own assumptions and those of others
around you
and always ask yourself is this person
telling me the truth and can i validate
it
is there any way i can know with
certainty that this is correct
and if you remain a skeptic until you
prove it out and the other thing
you know evan i look at is what's the
reputation of somebody i mean
you over time you build your own brand
if you're an entrepreneur
you start to realize that you work in a
world of many other people interacting
with you and they make assumptions about
you and they learn more and more over
time about who you are
you can't shortcut a reputation you have
to build it
and it takes a long time to build it up
and it's very easy to destroy and the
way you destroy it is you start lying to
people
the sales people that really succeed
are able to set targets on a monthly or
quarterly basis
and make them make them in other words
don't set targets you can't achieve if
you tell me you're going to get a
hundred thousand in sales in a week or a
month or whatever it is
get a hundred thousand in sales know
exactly your territory know what your
potential is and don't
over estimate the sales people that
really advance are the most coveted
are those that have stability to their
forecasts
that's what i'm talking about i love
salespeople men and women
that know what they can achieve and
consistently deliver on those numbers
if your mandate in your life is to just
build your personal brand you will fail
that's not how it works you have to be
transparent and honest about something
you know a lot about or at least feel
very passionate about and people
feel that connection and if they connect
because they believe you
and you're honest it'll work and i'll
tell you something you should understand
people smell a mile away that's true
real fast and if you just can't do it
without
them you are never going to get anywhere
so try and be honest and see if you can
actually play it out that way
not everybody can do it this guy built a
huge brand my son is a massive fan of
his because
he said dad that guy just tells the
truth wherever it goes
that's it that's why he's a rock star
tesla
probably eats up 60 70 of his
week but he's also in the battery
business and he's shooting stuff into
space
i get all that but the one that he cares
about the most
is the one that's having the biggest
challenges of growth which is tesla
right now
i know this because my son's an intern
for him and he's focused
yeah he doesn't waste his time he comes
in he works like and i think
everybody should find their tesla make
sure that they're staying focused on
that
i'm 28 located in vancouver without a
degree i have two years of experience in
college and a few years working
as an experience in sales my question is
what would be my best shot of making it
into the financial industry
am i too old to giving it a shot here's
what i've learned in life it's
really good to apprentice and learn
from masters that know a lot more and
have experience that you don't have
if you like financial services you've
got to go work for somebody in financial
services you have to be an
intern somewhere they're going to treat
you like crap they're going to pay you
nothing
but you're going to learn something if
you can spend a year
working for a company that you aspire to
actually be a manager in
or accelerate in that's a great outcome
for you now is that insurance
is in the credit industry is it for a
bank investment banker i don't know it's
really what you want to do because it
sounds like you want to
kind of pivot into the world of finance
the only way to play the game there
aaron is to go work in it and learn how
tough it is
and by the way they take guys like you
and they work you 20 hours a day
pay you nothing it's brutal but you
learn so much
do it for a year to 18 months and then
you can launch yourself
so look if you have the interest and the
desire and it sounds like you do
listen to what i just said go be an
intern
and good luck to you and by the way stop
your whining when you haven't had any
sleep
and you're doing seven days a week
remember i told you it was gonna be that
hard but it's worth it
i would personally rather invest someone
who has felt the sting of failure
and is motivated by the fear of failing
a fourth
time than someone who thinks they can
never fail because
it will visit everybody it just does
i've had plenty of failures
sometimes it's luck mike sometimes it's
just
being in the wrong place at the wrong
time three times in a row
and the fourth is the one that's going
to work i'd invest in that guy
sure i think he probably has learned
something from his
mistakes that's sometimes what they are
but failure
i mean it is just part of everybody's
life and there's
many ways to fail and it's really
easy to fail and very hard to succeed
even though i don't endorse
credit cards it's very hard to advance
your credit rating without having one
so it's good to get a credit card put
maybe a thousand dollar limit on it
and then start paying off you know use
200 bucks a month
and pay it off every month so i told my
son as soon as you get one trevor
put 50 bucks on the card yep and pay it
off and now he's got a pristine credit
rating and he's only ever put a few
thousand bucks through the car
everybody should understand that there's
no way to game that system you've got to
establish a credit rating
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
it's time for the question of the day i
wanna know what was your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week when you
watch something and get motivated
and just get inspired you have a 35
chance of actually following through but
when you get motivated and then you
actually create an
action plan for what you're going to do
you increase it from 35
to 91 chance of you actually following
through and
when you share your plan publicly that
jumps to
95 chance of following through so i want
that for you
i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week put it down
in the comments below
so i can celebrate you nobody's happy
100 of the time that's not how life
works my friends it just doesn't work
that way
but you know you got to get up in the
morning and ask yourself
what can i do today that solves for
three problems for me
one most of us are working i'm going to
be working till i drop dead
so i want to get something done towards
that how can i do something for my
family because family first
all the time what can you do with your
family and if you're married or living
with your significant other
what can i do to help them because a
happy significant other you know the
happy wife happy life well these days
happy significant other happy life so
you gotta balance all these three things
with your day you gotta take care of who
you're living with you gotta take care
of your family you got to take care of
your business
and when you're doing these things
you're going to find that they eat up 60
70 percent of your day
if your mind goes idle sometimes you can
get depressed it's happened to me too
you know things get on my mind i can't
sleep i worry about it
it's the wrong thing to do you've got to
think big picture
happiness is so hard to pursue and
anybody that tells you
they're happy 100 of the time is full of
[ __ ]
that is so not true everybody deals with
stress
regardless of your situation i have
people that are friends of mine that are
incredibly wealthy and they're miserable
i know people that are struggling
financially
and are happy with their families so it
has nothing to do with money
happiness it's not a destination it's a
journey
every day is different and life is going
to throw you
some crazy stuff remember this
conversation when it happens
stay focused don't go nuts
try and stay focused on the things that
matter in your life
your job your family
[Music]
those are basically it and the things
you love
you know if you love to play music you
love art you got to spend some time with
that too
if you want to see some awesome
motivation from tom bilyeu check it out
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe
and i'll see you there now i'm going to
tell you a story
and this story pisses people off
and it goes like this my wife
who happens to be british